but you know that government is all
obsessed by sex and gender yeah
it's endless oh yeah the last budget you
know that was
a gender budget the
they didn't have a lot of economic data
in the budget yeah it was supposed to be
a budget supposed to have economy
economic data it didn't have a lot of
economic data
but i think the word gender was in the
budget
300 times so and ndf
i will give you an example if you want
to build a pipeline
in canada with the new bill
c69 you need to do
a intersectorial sex
and gender analysis don't ask me what
that means
enter sexual sexual sexual sex
and gender analysis that's in the
legislation so
the sex and gender to build a pipeline
to build a pipeline yeah
a lot of people were talking about this
when we were in alberta yeah yeah the
sex and gender
expert will look at the impact
of building a pipeline in a rural
community
with men and women and the sex and so
it's crazy
it's a nonsense it's crazy so and this
government is obsessed about that
and i think that's why people are
looking for an alternative so
so a guy like trudeau it's hard to judge
what's really going on in someone's mind
but do you think he really
believes in the things that he's saying
when it comes to all of this gender
stuff or is it just
that it always leads to bigger
government and what he wants
fundamentally is bigger government
because he wants more power
he believes in state power yeah so so
that it's almost like it's a
it's an ends the ends justify the means
it's like you'll just say anything about
gender and all these things i think he
probably kind of believes
him but at the end they just give him
more power i i think first of all he
believe it
and i think also it's because he
believed in a big government
that will fix every problem in our
society
that's his philosophy and you know when
he said that you know
i don't know canada has no core identity
or or canada is the first supposed
national state
you know people
they understand understanding canada
that we
we are a nation we are not a post-nation
state
we are we have canadian values and we
share
the western civilization values so for
him
is a little bit like his father you know
the u.n and the world is important and
the mass immigration
and open borders and everybody everybody
can come to canada
uh that's what people they don't like
that in canada they want us to respect
our immigration system
and and having a sustainable immigration
system
so trudeau i think wants to build a big
government
and at the end he believed in a supra
national government
you know he uh he just signed in 2010
uh with the u.n there's the un unpa
un parliamentary assembly it's uh
it's a group that proven to promote a
world government
like the uh the eu parliament that will
be able to uh write legislation that
will be
abiding with and with
countries and they will lost their
sovereignty and to do in 2010
uh promote that and believe in that so
it's all about the u.n it's all about
the big government
and it's all about him trying to
find the right policies that will solve
every problems
but that's not the case just less
regulation
more freedom you'll have more prosperity
i think people are
are tired of that in canada it almost
strikes me as it's like a psychological
condition more than anything else
it's just like sort of what like it's
obvious to me that you believe in just
that the individual can
yeah to the best of their ability solve
their problems not all of them
but to the best of barriers absolutely
and i think that this other set of
people believe
that i don't know i would view it as
almost a very dim way of viewing humans
that if we all weren't controlled that
endless evil would spread everywhere
or something to that yeah i think they
believe that canadians are children
and you know they must follow regulation
and
but i trust you know i have faith in
people i have faith that they have the
ability
the dignity and the right to make their
own decision and determine their own
destiny
that's important for us that's important
for me and yes you can make you can make
a mistake
but you'll be responsible of your
success
and your your your mistake that's how
you learn in a society
uh that's why you know uh speaking about
that people
like me a little bit and they're looking
at jordan peterson and they're saying
well bernie personal responsibility and
jordan also is his book it's all about
that you know
clean your your your room before
before cleaning the world so so be
responsible of your action
and that's what we want to do and that's
what as a politician i want to
i want to do well i mentioned it before
we sat down but i may as well say it on
camera that when i go to these events
with jordan and especially the 12 or 15
we did in canada
i say something about trudeau and the
whole audience booze i say something
about you and the whole audience goes
crazy so
so something good is happening um you've
mentioned uh borders a couple of times
yes this does seem to now be the hot one
at least in the united states
where we seem to be caught between
either a wall or open borders and
it's such a it's it's not a real choice
i don't think it's not a sensible choice
and in one hand if you're for the wall
they say you're racist if you say
you're for open borders then you're an
anarchist or whatever it is
so what would be the right way to look
at borders if you want to maintain your
national sovereignty
yeah and that's the debate that we're
having right now in canada because as
you know
we have people who are crossing the
border uh
from the state of new york to quebec and
um
they they are asking to this they said
that they're refugees and
actually they are not real refugees you
know your life is not in danger
in the state of new york uh but that
being said they think it is
they didn't perceive yeah perceive yeah
yeah but um but the last two years i
think more than 40
000 people across the border illegally
so the trudeau government
doesn't want to fix that and that's a
big issue in canada
so uh what i'm asking as a politician
we have an immigration system and that
is
it it was going very well at point
system so it's a privilege to be
canadians and we want people who come
here
to share our canadian values or basic
western civilization values
and and it's a privilege so we have
three kind of immigrants in canada
the rainification of family the refugees
and the economic immigrant the person
that will come because they have a job
because the business wasn't able to find
a canadian for that job
so they are coming they have a job and
usually it's easier to integrate a
society if you have a job
but we don't need to build a wall
between canada and us we just need to be
sure to respect
our immigration system and the way to do
that is to
have a discussion with president trump
about the third safe
country agreement we and we have an
agreement with the u.s about that
and to fix that loophole so people who
are crossing at a real point of entry
it's okay but people who are crossing
and not a real point of entry
we they must go back to the u.s and we
must have an agreement with the us about
that and i think we can have that kind
of argument
if we sit with the trump administration
but at the same time
we must be clear that people who are
coming to canada
must come from the right reason and
these people who are crossing
our border right now 40
of them will have to be deported because
they're not real refugees
so it's a big cost for canadian
taxpayers
because these people will be deported
maybe in three years from now
so we must fix that and we have a strong
position in our platform
yes we'll fix that at the border but we
don't need to impose a wall we don't
need to create a wall
but the most important we need to focus
on more economic immigrants
that's what we need in canada and a
little bit less of refugees and a little
bit less of reunification
of family so that's a strong position
but
saying that uh yes it's a risk in canada
when you see that as a politician
but i'm taking that risk and yeah what
do you make of the libertarian argument
that is pro-open border because i've had
many guests here that are libertarian
that take that position
i've never been convinced of it i
actually i just i don't understand the
fundamental premise because as you said
earlier it's if you're a nation a nation
has borders that's just
otherwise everything is just an
amorphous blob but what i'm sure you
hear this when you're in libertarian
circles so what do you make of that
argument
yeah that's not coming from the left
that's coming from uh
yeah absolutely so our party is we're
not anti-immigration and we're not open
borders and for mass immigration so what
we want it's a little bit less immigrant
250 000 a year like we had under stephen
upper
not 350 000 a year to do increase
to the government they increase that by
um uh 40 so
what i'm saying uh when people say oh
you know open border is good it's not
it's not everybody that can be part of a
nation
if you don't support our values if you
are i don't know pro sharia law
that's against our values that's again
freedom
between men and women equality between
men and women
the respect of the rule of law if you
want to impose a new
rule of law sharia law
the integration won't be very well in
our society
so these people uh
much they must share our values our
western civilization values so that's
why if you have an open border
and you want everybody from everywhere
to come to canada
that will create tension and and dislike
in the population
and that's happening actually in europe
actually right now
are you able to point to that that's the
one thing that i've never understood
that europe is having all of these
integration problems
merkel has basically said she's screwed
up yeah you know after letting a million
people in
yeah are you able to point to that and
say you see they might have
that's the warning i'm doing that you
know jonathan telling are telling me
maxime
nothing happened in canada it's a great
country i said yes it is a great country
but i want this country to be like that
in 20 years from now
so that's why we must have the
discussion right now
and people who are coming to canada must
share our values
if not you know they're not welcome
because the integration will be
very difficult and that's that's the
trudeau government policy on
extreme ritual terrorism so you know
for trudeau diversity is our strength a
strength
and for me it's unity who is our
strength as a country
and but trudeau is always pushing for
more diversity more diversity more
diversity
and i said that and i tweet about that
more diversity
won't help our country at the end it
will destroy
our country i know that we there's
canada is a diverse country with people
coming from different
countries and with different culture but
at the end
they integrated our society because they
believe in our freedom in our
values in a and they want to share
our traditions and our heritage
celebrate our heritage
so that's what we want and we need to
have that discussion in canada and and i
think that discussion actually
so that's why i don't believe in open
borders i think it will
create uh too much diversity
and i want people to come in our country
to share our values
and it's a privilege to be canadians and
like it's a privilege to be an american
so we must choose our immigrants and we
did that for the last
35 years and that was very successful
for our country
and people and it's interesting you're
only trying to roll it back to
what it was forty percent less i mean
it's not like you're doing something
it's not like you're saying we're not
letting anyone in no 100 people are
coming yeah just going back to
you know it's a couple years ago yeah
and it is just
radical because the last poll in canada
49 of canadians said that they want
fewer immigrants and only six percent
six percent of canadians said that they
want more immigrants
so who is the radical maxim bernie or
justin trudeau which just tend to
increase that by 40 percent so that's a
fact
and and that's what canadian i think
they're fed up with it's
extremely extreme multiculturalism uh
the cult of diversity uh you know
too much is too much and i think
canadian can see that in the future if
you go on
on that road will have more
problem and the integration would be
more difficult
and but under 10 team immigrants and
people
came in our country and they built this
country
so but they came for the right reason
and they're proud to be canadians yeah
but the liberals and and the
conservative are doing identity politics
and they try to please every special
interest group but every special ethnic
groups also
so you know and they call that outreach
but for me
the policies must be the same for every
canadians and
we don't do any difference with your
your race your gender or what
so for us it is not important but the
canadian government is playing like
it's playing that that uh
they're doing these policies and i think
that won't
that won't be good at the end for our
country yeah so speaking of these
policies
i've also seen you on twitter you're not
a big fan of what's going on at the un
these days
no i'm not to say the least uh can you
can you lay out why the u.n
why why you're so down on me but it's
it's a it's first of all it's a
dysfunctional organization
um uh just as example i think the last
two years they've ordered 21
resolutions against israel on human
rights
and only one or two resolutions against
china
or cuba or venezuela
so you know and the countries that are
on that human rights committees or you
know
all the bad guys yeah it's all the bad
guys and iraq
china uh uh all all the bad guy
all the dictatorships so so it's it's a
joke
but do you wanna want to impose their
vision of the world
on other countries and you know i was
against recently uh
against the compact on migration
and you know they want migrants to be
normal it is not normal people must be
able to live in their country
we must try to bring peace and
prosperity and
that's that's the most important but no
they want that to be normal there
there's 250 million people
that are migrants on the globe
and they want to facilitate that so and
the trudeau government signed that
agreement but it was
they were saying oh it's not binding
it's not binding but at the end why is
signing an agreement
and if you said that you will follow all
that
but yeah it's not binding but you will
put legislation in place to be in line
with the agreement that you sign so that
will have an effect
on our country at the end it won't be
imposed by the u.n
it will be imposed by a legitimate
elected canadian government so
which is ironic because the paris accord
was non-binding too
yeah and he was all about the power
absolutely yeah yeah you're right
so i think people there and
i think i was very clear about that and
i had a lot of support about that that
migrant
come back and people understand that you
know we have our sovereignty as a
country
and we must be able to select our
immigrants
and so that's coming from the u.n so yes
you're right
i don't like the un i think that they're
not so efficient
and um and i'm clear about that
yeah do you guys have a strain you know
we're seeing in europe now where there's
nationalist parties that there does seem
to be a strain
of sort of ethno-nationalism or
something that has a different
racial kind of connotation to it do you
guys have
a strain of that in canada because it
seems to me that i think what's
happening and we're starting to see it
here is that if
if the good liberals and and the good
libertarians and the people who just
want to live and let live
if they don't start making some advances
against
this radical leftism that's moving
there's going to be a lot of people that
break
in a bad way yeah and in a weird way i
wouldn't be able to blame them
and i say that as someone that has no
racism in my heart but they would be
left with no alternative as they watch
their country
crumble do you have any of that in
canada no we don't
and it's a good news but at the end
that's why we must have this discussion
and and i don't fear to have this
discussion
for me there's no political correctness
there's no taboo subject
and we need to have the discussion and
i'm having that discussion with
canadians
and i think it is time to have the
discussion if we wait too long
that can happen in our country yeah so
so right now i would imagine there's
probably some people on the right
that are saying well bernier if he gains
too much
strength it'll sort of split the right
and then that gives us true
i mean this is always the argument
against libertarians right and i say
this is someone that
i voted for gary johnson and you know
and i get it
the more at some micro level when
it's you the third party is usually the
libertarian party that's usually going
to take from the conservatives more than
the lefties
and then then there is an argument then
you're always going to end up with a
lefty government
i suspect as the guy lead in this thing
you don't buy that argument
i don't in the long term i don't buy
that but actually it is
the only argument that my opponent the
conservative party of canada
has um and so that's their whole thing
oh yeah you vote for this guy you're
going to fracture us they have a weak
leader
there's no conviction there you know the
conservative are doing a lot of polling
polling and focus group and survey
but they're not doing politics by
conviction and i'm doing politics by
conviction
and we must speak about what we believe
openly with passion and conviction and
that's what i'm doing that's a big
difference with me and
russia and andrew scheer uh
tried to please everybody and he said
actually
he was with the toronto sun and he said
my party he is a centrist centuries
pragmatic political party open for a lot
of ideas
for a lot of people so what he's saying
is he doesn't have any principle
he doesn't have any conviction doesn't
have any vision for the country
he wants to please everybody but at the
end when you please everybody you end up
pleasing nobody
so that's the conservative or not i
think i'm not happy with him but they're
telling me maxine
we want to win and yes you are splitting
the vote
but i'm saying in a democracy
the vote it's always split if you don't
want anyone to speak the vote
it would be a dictator you don't have so
so what i'm telling them is andrew she
when i was with him when i was a
conservative
um he was not winning against justin
trudeau
he was always six to eight points behind
justin trudeau and maxim bernie is not
with henry xi right now
and and russia is not winning he's
behind andrew
behind justin trudeau by four to six
point now
so he's not able to win so what i'm
saying to people
vote for your values vote for what you
believe in
be part of the change be with us we
have the momentum right now we have the
real conservative
policies and ideas and come with us and
we
will see what will happen maybe we can
be
we can have the balance of power in in a
parliamentary system
we can be in power also i don't know i
don't know what will happen but i know
that we have the momentum
so you think it's a risk worth taking
regardless even if even if at the end of
the day
the party splits or not the party
because it's two separate parties but
the votes are split enough that you end
up with trudeau again you think it's
just
long term it's what you have to do
basically you have to vote for what you
believe
you know and then giving them another
alternative
and you know why you will vote for a
politician that is telling you something
and at the end he won't do any reform he
won't do anything because he will look
at the poll and he won't be able to do
that
i'm speaking about real conservative
reform
before after and during an election time
every time so yes that there's a risk
over there that justin crudo be erected
but maybe you will have it would be
erected only as a minority government
and if it's a minority government and we
are there with a lot of seats
we can be the difference and we can
impose
our reform to the government or we
reverse the government
we don't know what we can do but i don't
know what can happen but i'm telling
them
that's a risk but you know
vote vote for what you think will be
good for this country in the long term
that's what we're doing right now we
they they like the poll that's why i'm
telling you that's the only argument
that they have
yeah uh but the goal and i i think i can
defeat justin trudeau
the most important from me actually is
to be able to have candidates
all across the country in every riding
and will be able to have that so we're
not a regional party we are a national
party
in quebec and outside quebec and all
across the country and also i'll be
i will be present at the national debate
on on the national tv during the
during the election campaign in
september october
and that would be important for me as
the leader of a new party to be there
and i think i'll be able to question the
other leader to
to to challenge them and that will help
our party at the end
so we can be a big surprise and i'm
telling people
come with us vote for what you believe
be part of the change
and and we'll be able to do something i
don't know what would be the end
result of all that but i can tell you
that
we are able to change the country for
the better yeah
that that should be the ending but i'm
not quite i'm not quite done yet but
that was
that was that was the ending portion
here in a way that was your that was
your closing stump speech there
what do you make of um sort of the the
state we haven't talked at all about
religion it's one of the
themes that we've talked a lot about
here and i know you're obviously
familiar with jordan peterson's work
um that it seems that the way
that western countries have say moved
off of judeo-christian values
that they've replaced everything with a
big state i
actually don't know what you're really
oh yeah actually that's that's
i believe in that and then that happened
in quebec in my own province in quebec
at the financial level
you know we had the relationship with
the state and the church in quebec
in the 1950 1960 16
and and after that you know we we did at
the potential level a quiet revolution
and so we replaced we replaced the
the church by a bigger state
and that happened in quebec and we still
have a big
fat government at the prime charlotte
level in quebec that's why you know
quebec is a poor province in canada we
have a kind of a formula in canada in
the constitution
we call that the equalization formula
the rich provinces are giving money to
poor provinces and quebec
received equalization money for the last
50 years
so so because bad economic policies at
the financial level and because of a big
state at the provincial level does it
ever work
there's no shifting the money ever work
i mean why did they have to do it for 50
years if this was so the good policy
yeah yeah
it's but politicians like to to give
money and to
but so so what you're saying about the
re
when i think we did that in quebec and
and at the federal level
with the trudeau government they want a
bigger state absolutely
so i agree with jordan when he said when
he said that
uh that was the case at the branch level
in quebec a little bit
more evident but also at the federal
level so people want
politicians want a bigger government and
and
the the more bigger the government is
the more power they have
the more regulation they're doing the
more influence they will have
and and so for for me
i don't buy that so as a libertarian in
government which as i started this is an
odd thing because it's the only type of
people that want to
scale back the very thing they're
becoming part of yeah are you worried at
all that everything has become political
that it seems politics has sort of
replaced sports
at least here in the united states the
way we talk about politicians is the way
you used to talk about
athletes we worship these people who've
never accomplished anything but they're
good on sound bites or trudeau has nice
hair and wears nice socks
although you're clearly you're doing all
right in the sock game but
but that we we worship these people who
should have
you know if we were doing this right
would have almost no control over us and
yet we we've elevated them to some
magical state
that's got to be just weird for you
personally as someone that
you want to scale this thing back and
yet you have to be part
i have to be part of that i have to be
part of that to do that you're
absolutely right
uh but yes and i think that
the population sometimes they're putting
too much
too much uh fate in a politician
to change things you know and that's
what i'm telling to people you know
i will i will put forward the policies
that we believe in
but after that you know one will have
more competition
no more corporate welfare a government
that respect the constitution
and and will all these extreme
multiculturalism policies will
you know that's that is there to buy
votes and ethnic voting
and with different communities will
abolish these policies
so i'm telling them i'll do that but at
the same time i'm doing that because i
believe in you
because i don't want to save you for
every individual problems that you can
have in your life
i want you to be responsible that's a
little bit
uh but you know i'm the only politician
who speak like that
and for me you know i believe in free
markets i believe in competition
but when you don't have competition it
is fun
in politics you know other politicians
are too afraid
to say that and for me uh that's that's
great because
i don't have uh political competition on
what i'm seeing
but you're right you know people must be
responsible and we must have a smaller
government
and i want i want to have that job to be
sure
to do what i want to do and help people
in the right way
by giving them back their their
responsibility and
giving them back their own money and uh
giving them back their increasing their
purchasing power
so all the things that if they have more
money in the par in their pockets they
will
they'll be able to do more things and so
for them or for their family so that's
uh
that's what i want to do in politics and
i like that actually it's my best time
in politics right now
yeah all right i normally don't end an
interview asking
a favor but my favor is this if you can
make this thing work in canada
can you then send somebody down to fix
the libertarians in the united states
because our libertarians need some help
i mean but your voice and someone that's
speaking
clarity on libertarian issues yeah
because we have a lot of
talkers that are doing it we have a lot
of youtubers and think tanks
that do it really well but for whatever
reason and i i again i voted for gary
johnson i think he's a
really nice man but he wasn't a great
candidate we need
that what you're presenting so if you've
got anybody
can you can you send them our way when
you're done with this name don't deal
sounds good all right well it was a
pleasure thank you so much for coming in
and for more on maxime you can check out
people's party of canada.ca
[Music]
you